the Joe Rogan experience you know snow
snow it's great
well watch this [ __ ] on TV this is my
[ __ ]
watch what on TV the food that made
America anybody watch that you know what
is it yo for the channel no it's a maybe
it's a History Channel or one of them
stations but they go into the Hershey
Company the same people did the men that
made a man yeah AME docu-series I didn't
know I didn't see that one but that
right that one about the men and made
America yeah I gotta watch it good yo
they cover Kellogg they cover Kellogg's
yo check out hot Chow log star but hold
on let him tell the Kellogg story cuz
you didn't believe this
okay Kellogg star because he's a doctor
with a little they call it sanitary but
the quality sanitarium yes we had
whatever it is anyways the doctor yeah
no sanitarium there's an it's a tidal
Creek Sanitarium
yes so he's there I never knew that
[ __ ] [ __ ] big Kellogg
no Kellogg was a [ __ ]
he invented cereal to keep people from
how old ox and B are in cereal boxes
forever he invents cereal to calm
people's sexual desire because they
because they because they was sick there
and he's what they thought the best way
to get the nutrients he would bake
orders drained together and then break
it up and no he did pour milk his
brother actually was the one that was
like piss on milk in it Golden Grahams
immediately Nath gonna check out the
punchline of the story right so
Kellogg's is doing this [ __ ] his
brothers like y'all listen it's money in
this we could sell this but Kellogg's
he's the doctor he's already making but
he's like nah man look his brother's
little look dyslexia he ain't really
kind of got it it's got these sons but
look we're doing all that son let's go
to work and do what I tell you right
so he's going to go do what he tells him
and then one guy comes over to the
sanatorium no money can't afford to pay
he has to work it off right so they let
him work it off right he's working he's
eating the cereal every morning and he's
just checking out the sanitarium and he
goes he looks around
his name is mr. post misterpost yeah huh
he leaves the sanitarium and before
Kellogg starts Kellogg CEO mr. post
started post Suomi and blue oh I forgot
about post yo for real it was a beef was
it like sir you briefed oh it was so
you'll be food for the whole pepsi-cola
right you access a black people of Pepsi
Cola right how somebody's white doing
anything you know why black people like
pip sounds like you try and be racist
right and he explains story to me back
in like the 30s with coca-cola and Pepsi
was the - vine of bottling companies and
coca-cola was smashed and Pepsi on sales
like like 125 minutes like three million
in sales per year right and Pepsi needed
to do something to get a different
audience so Pepsi painted basically coke
to be either racist or not really caring
about the black community and Pepsi was
the first corporation they started
putting black people on the cover of the
posters and don't be in affluent like
like doctors nurses they because
everything you saw him was like Aunt
Jemima [ __ ] but I have been a MC was the
first ones to start doing that and Pepsi
hired an ad agency twelve black guys I
think was in Louisiana to go out and do
juke joints and touch the black
community and what Pepsi did was like
quantity wise like say if you had ten
ounces of Pepsi ten ounce of coke pepsi
cope with charts like 20 cent and Pepsi
with charge like 10 cent but basically
getting doubled you want you give a
[ __ ] sugar you don't matter you could
charge it up right yeah so that's the
reason and didn't if you think about
that through generations generation
that's the reason why a person could be
disconnected from a certain brand you
said think about it if you if you like
if you at home right you got Pepsi coke
and then you hear somebody said man we
don't drink that coke man
white people soda you don't said you
won't drag it in and that's what I did
and they it's a book called it's called
it's a book called the real Jamie pop it
up the real Pepsi challenge the real
Pepsi challenge that to us and I think
this would be I looked into trying to
get the rights to if some kind of way I
got blocked early on maybe I had a right
Jew tank laying on my teeth how one
pioneering company broke the color
barrier in 1940s American businesses Wow
and see that you wouldn't see impact in
you wasn't seeing posters of of a
working mom you were just seeing like
serving stuff and that's when audio
version in that book story you could see
the view could just see you really you
could just see the outfits they was
wearing and like the Pepsi dudes they
was a Pepsi but it was a Pepsi there was
just to have money to go throw parties
that [ __ ] yep Pepsi it up pep it up do
you know the coca-cola to this day is
made with cocaine now to know they use
coca leaves and then they extract
medical cocaine from that and then
there's a company that's yep there's a
company that extracts it for them and
makes medical cocaine and they have they
have coca leaves that are shipped to
coca-cola to make coca-cola there's a
certain flavor that those coca leaves
give it no cocaine anymore
coca leaves no but there's a company
that's connected to it that actually
uses those coca leaves and extracts the
medical there is medical cocaine yeah
they use it for different surgeries and
show like that even a nut right well
yeah in the series the food that made
America they go into coca-cola crazy
they could still buy coke
hey yo he said but the events of Coca
Cola was hooked on coke come on another
drug oh he was hooked on uh I forgot you
can look it up right he sucked also
other morphine he's hooked on morphine
right so he's trying to counter it he's
trying to counter his cocaine basically
oh my God he's speedballing but
but check it out but the cocoa the cocoa
leaf by the cocoa plant was actually an
african plant you know I mean we always
think of it as being a Colombian and
like coffee
how coffee all came from Ethiopia is
that kind of party to it he make he
makes cocoa he makes cocoa - cocoa
planning few other ingredients together
and uh he made coca-cola
so he made a cocktail ended up take off
the morphine heh yeah in the original
formula is still unknown I mean it would
be like coca-cola when it had cocaine in
it you like crack streets coked up
exactly [ __ ] really thirsty now
heal it right now
you imagine what that what was the
decision like when did they all get
together dry him we got to take the
[ __ ] cocaine out of coca-cola when
did they get together and together how
did they did it for people like we had
with dental in like issues with their
mouths yeah yeah okay
lidocaine they using surgery okay yeah
when I had my deviated septum fixed I
had a broken nose they straighten it out
and they flood it with lidocaine to numb
it it's like a cousin of cocaine yeah it
doesn't get you high makes you feel like
[ __ ] it doesn't get you high but you
feel like disconnected and weird like
they gave me a pretty good dose when
they fix my nose and I remember I went
to a restaurant like either that night
or the day after I think it was that
night and I was I was feeling terrible
like I'm like I don't I can't taste
anything I feel all shaky and weird like
I'm not on cocaine but it's cuz do
anything to your appetite or anything
yeah I didn't wasn't that hungry well
yeah it [ __ ] with me it just made me
feel shitty I just felt like I felt like
my heart was beating too fast
I felt weird and it just felt like
something was off it didn't make any
sense but they use it just to numb you
up for surgeries it's real common I
never had none
[Applause]